[Musik]
SALLY: Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Mittagessen.
Gut, wir haben schon Nachmittag,
aber wir hatten hier jetzt ganz doll Hunger.
Ich bin schon der Fan von schnellen Gerichten.
Deswegen mache ich heute ein Gemüsecurry. Das Ganze ist sogar vegan.
Da werden sich die Veganer freuen.
Ein Gemüsecurry aus vielen frischen Zutaten,
weil wir mittags einfach gern gesund essen, muss ich echt sagen.
Also es gibt auch schon einmal Situationen,
da bestellen wir uns einen Döner oder eine Pizza,
aber danach bin ich einfach hundemüde und ich bin eher der Fan von
Vitaminen, Gemüse, gesundes leckeres Essen.
Ich habe jetzt hier einmal so eine Gemüseauswahl getroffen,
die einfach mein Kühlschrank hergegeben hat.
Ihr könnt natürlich das Gemüse nehmen, das ihr dahabt.
Ihr könnt das Ganze auch mit Fleisch zubereiten
und z. B. Hähnchen-, Puten- oder Rindfleisch benutzen
– könnt ihr auch machen.
Ihr könnt aber auch Fisch oder Garnelen mit einarbeiten.
Aber wie gesagt, wir sind jetzt heute auf dem Gemüsetrip.
Deswegen ein Gemüsecurry. Ich benutze jetzt 1 Brokkoli,
2 rote Zwiebeln, 1 Knoblauchzehe,
etwas Ingwer ist hier unten versteckt,
2 Karotten, Zucchini, Kohlrabi.
Dann brauche ich zum Anbraten etwas Öl.
Ich nehme jetzt Sesamöl.
Ihr könnt auch Kokos-, Sonnenblumen- oder Rapsöl nehmen.
Tomatenmark, rote Currypaste, Speisestärke zum Binden,
jeweils 400 ml Gemüsebrühe und Kokosmilch light aus der Dose,
Kichererbsen (abgetropft), etwas Spinat, Frühlingszwiebeln
und dazu gibt es gleich bei uns noch einen Reis.
Weil das Rezept superschnell geht,
würde ich sogar zuerst einmal den Reis ansetzen.
Ich habe Basmati; ihr könnt aber auch einen Naturreis
oder auch einen dunklen Basmati nehmen.
Ich habe jetzt diesen genommen, weil den hatte ich da.
250 g Basmatireis, 500 ml Wasser (also einfach das Doppelte)
- ich mache nämlich die Quellreismethode -,
etwas Salz.
JOSH: Kommt es aus einer Bergquelle?
SALLY: [Lacht] Aus der Bergquelle.
Dann kurz verrühren und dann werde ich hier den Deckel schließen,
uii... den Deckel verschließen, das Ganze aufkochen lassen,
die Hitze reduzieren und dann darf der Reis einfach noch ziehen,
bis er gar ist. Also auf der Packung steht das auch meist;
je nachdem, welchen Reis ihr habt, dürfte es ca. 20 Minuten dauern.
Naturreis geht ein bisschen... nicht so schnell [Lacht].
Ich wollte den Satz anders formulieren.
Naturreis braucht ein bisschen länger, wollte ich sagen. Genau.
Der Reis ist jetzt da.
Im Prinzip werde ich jetzt das ganze Gemüse vorbereiten,
d. h., die Zwiebeln und Knoblauchzehe schälen und fein würfeln.
Hier bitte immer darauf achten
- und ich hoffe, mein Team schaut jetzt auch zu... Sarah! -,
dass man hier vorne beim Schneiden die Wurzel nicht wegschneidet,
denn diese Wurzel hält beim Schneiden die Zwiebel zusammen.
Das ist wichtig, damit ihr sie gleichmäßig schneiden könnt
und sie beim Schneiden nicht auseinanderfällt.
[Musik]
Dann die Zwiebeln halbieren.
Wie gesagt, die Wurzel hält jetzt alles zusammen.
Falls ihr jetzt Ringe schneiden wollt, also Halbringe,
dann einfach so quer nehmen und so schneiden.
Wenn ihr sie würfeln wollt, hier nicht durchschneiden,
sondern wirklich nur bis kurz vorher.
Schaut, dann bleibt die Zwiebel schön zusammen.
Dann den Tunnelgriff anwenden und hier feinhacken.
Dann habt ihr gleichmäßige Zwiebeln und sie fällt nicht auseinander.
Das Video schneiden wir jetzt als Kurz-Tutorial für Sarah zusammen,
damit sie das Zwiebelschneiden lernt, oder? Doch, gell?
[Musik]
Beim Aufkochen darauf achten, dass der Reis natürlich nicht überkocht
und dann die Hitze reduzieren.
Gut! Das passiert nicht mehr.
Die Knoblauchzehe dann ein bisschen flachdrücken, schälen
und auch fein hacken.
Ich habe mir gerade überlegt:
Soll ich einmal ein Video machen mit Gemüseschneidetechniken?
Also wie man Gemüse richtig verarbeitet?
Denn dann kann ich zum einen darauf eingehen,
welche Messer man am besten dafür benutzt und zum anderen,
wie man welches Gemüse verarbeitet – Strunk rein, Strunk raus,
wie schält man, was kann man von der Schale noch benutzen.
Ich glaube, so ein Basic Video wäre cool, weil dann kann ich nämlich
in Zukunft solche Rezepte wie heute recht kurzhalten,
weil ich echt viel Gemüse zu schneiden habe.
Dann kann ich immer auf das andere Video hinweisen.
Was meint ihr? Schreibt es mir gern in die Kommentare!
JOSH: Ja!
SALLY: Ich finde es auch gut, weil ich bin ja eher immer so Basic.
Ich zeige immer erst einmal alles, was Basic ist und
dann kann man darauf die Erweiterung durchführen. Ja, finde ich gut.
Jetzt habe ich hier die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel.
Das Öl gebe ich in einen Topf oder in eine große Pfanne.
Das Öl habe ich jetzt erwärmt.
Jetzt kommen da die Zwiebel- und Knoblauchwürfel hinein.
Da immer darauf achten: Nicht mit der scharfen Messerseite,
sondern mit dem Messerrücken! Aber ich höre jetzt auf zu erklären.
Das machen wir echt in einem separaten Video, wenn ihr das möchtet.
Diese jetzt kurz bei mittelhoher Hitze anbraten.
In der Zeit nehme ich auch schon einmal ein Stück Ingwer.
Beim Ingwer ist es so – den müsst ihr im Prinzip gar nicht schälen,
sondern ihr könnt mit der Rückseite eines Löffels
- eigentlich ein kleiner Löffel, aber ich hatte jetzt keinen -,
die harten Stellen entfernen und den Rest ruhig dranlassen.
Das macht echt nichts! Diesen jetzt auch fein hacken.
Wenn ihr es schärfer wollt, dann gern mehr Ingwer nehmen.
Wenn nicht so arg, dann weniger. Den Ingwer direkt dazu geben.
Dann könnt ihr einfach das Gemüse, was ihr noch habt...
Also den Brokkoli werde ich in Röschen teilen,
gewaschen habe ich schon alles.
Hier ist es so, dass ich den oberen Teil so verwende.
Den unteren Teil, den Strunk,
werde ich schälen und auch mitbenutzen, also klein hacken.
Die Karotten sind Bio, d. h., diese brauche ich auch nicht zu schälen.
Ich gucke schon immer,
dass ich so viel wie möglich vom Gemüse mit verwerte.
Alles, was ich nicht brauche, landet meist sogar in Gemüsebrühe.
Also da einfach so wenig wie möglich wegschmeißen.
Hier könnt ihr gern auch einmal den Deckel draufgeben,
bisschen runterschalten, dass die Zwiebeln nicht verbrennen.
[Musik]
Die Zucchini halbiere ich. Wenn sie zu groß ist und das Innere hier
zu kernig und zu wässrig ist, nehme ich das meist heraus.
Bei ganz jungen Zucchinis lasse ich es meist drin,
aber dieses Kernige hier ist später sowieso nicht ganz so gut.
Da könnt ihr es echt herausnehmen.
Ich habe einmal das Buch „Böses Gemüse“ gelesen.
Eigentlich habe ich früher das Innere der Zucchini
dann auch weiterbenutzt, weil ich so gedacht habe:
„Boah, voll die Lebensmittelverschwendung!“
Aber seitdem ich das Thema mit den Lektinen
so ein bisschen angerissen habe, Thema Ernährung und...
Man weiß es nicht.
Es gibt ja immer verschiedene Studien in der Wissenschaft.
Eine Studie besagt, dass eben Lektine gerade viel in Kernen
und Nachtschattengewächsen stecken, also Zucchini, Tomaten, Paprika,
auch in der Schale, und diese nicht ganz so gesund sind für den Darm.
Seitdem ich das gelesen habe, muss ich sagen,
nehme ich das Innere der Zucchini echt gern heraus,
weil ich mir dann denke: „Dann erspare ich mir das!“ Es ist immer...
Es ist immer... Ich denke, wenn man nach jeder Studie geht,
darf man gar nichts mehr essen,
aber das ist auch nicht gesund [Lacht].
Deswegen glaube ich,
sollte man eine gesunde Ernährung für sich finden, weil ich glaube,
die gesunde Ernährung gibt es gar nicht.
Deswegen probiere ich immer und versuche immer,
mich abwechslungsreich zu ernähren, mit viel Obst und Gemüse.
Aber wenn ich nach allem gehen würde, was die Wissenschaft sagt,
dürfte ich echt gar nichts mehr essen.
Aber deswegen habe ich es angerissen,
habe ich jetzt da z. B. kein schlechtes Gewissen mehr,
dass ich hier die sehr lektinhaltigen Kerne
aus der Mitter herausgenommen habe und sie nicht weiter benutze.
[Musik]
Dann einfach schon einmal das Gemüse da hineingeben
und das restliche Gemüse noch schneiden.
Ich hätte fast den Ela-Topf nehmen können.
Ich dachte so für 4 Personen, aber jetzt eskaliert es wieder,
weil ich zu viel Gemüse wollte.
[Musik]
Egal, Kohlrabi kommt jetzt auch hinein.
Wenn ihr das Gemüse für ein paar Minuten angebraten habt,
kommt direkt die Currypaste dazu.
Den Löffel werde ich hier noch ein bisschen
- ist fast hängengeblieben – auswaschen.
Dann Tomatenmark. Bisschen mitbraten, ebenso die Stärke zum Binden.
[Bratgeräusche]
Dann alles mit Gemüsebrühe und Kokosmilch ablöschen.
Das riecht lecker!
Ihr könnt selbst die Intensität des Geschmacks bestimmen.
Also wenn ihr sagt, ich mag Curry,
dann nehmt ruhig ein bisschen mehr Currypaste.
Wenn ihr nicht ganz so der Fan davon seid,
dann lasst sie weg oder nehmt einfach weniger.
Schmeckt natürlich auch ohne Currypaste gut,
aber ist dann kein Curry mehr.
Dann ist es wirklich ein bisschen geschmacksneutraler
und sollte dann auch noch besser gewürzt werden, muss ich sagen.
Jetzt kann ich das hier schön köcheln lassen,
mit Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken.
Wenn ihr möchtet,
gern noch einen Spritzer Zitronen- oder Limettensaft.
Also da dürft ihr auch gern selbst bestimmen.
Dann lasse ich es wirklich eigentlich nur noch kurz köcheln,
dass die Sauce bindet. Das Gemüse mag ich gern ein bisschen bissfest.
Das soll jetzt gar nicht weichgekocht werden.
Kurz vor Ende kommt noch der Spinat mit den Kichererbsen dazu.
Dann bin ich schon fertig, kann in der Zeit schön aufräumen
und dann ist das Essen fertig, der Reis ist fertig.
So, jetzt noch geschwind abschmecken.
Also dass ich die Gewürzmühle vorher nicht hier drin hatte
und ich jedes Mal habe dort rüber laufen müssen...
Diese Küchenorganisation hat sich sowas von gelohnt!
[Musik]
Leckerschmecker!
Fertiggekocht. Ah, die Frühlingszwiebeln schneide ich noch.
Diese streue ich dann nämlich noch darauf.
[Musik]
Da das Rezept jetzt unerwartet sogar vegan wurde,
darf heute Volkan probieren.
Er hat nämlich nicht oft das Vergnügen, bei mir probieren zu können,
weil oft ist es nicht ganz so vegan.
Aber heute ist es vegan.
VOLKAN: Hallo.
SALLY: Hallo. Also ich mache das jetzt so:
Ich nehme jetzt ein Schälchen Reis;
den mache ich jetzt erst einmal hier rein,
denn ich finde, das Essen muss auch immer schön angerichtet sein.
So, dann richte ich es hier hin. Das lasse ich jetzt noch darauf.
Und dann... Oh, wir hätten noch Sesam darüberstreuen können.
So. Zwiebel.
Biraz susam da getireyim. (Ich hole noch etwas Sesam.)
Ich hole noch Sesam. Magst du Sesam?
VOLKAN: Ich liebe Sesam. Ich mag Sesam, Tahin... Alles aus Sesam.
Und Sesamstraße. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Afiyet olsun. (Guten Appetit.)
VOLKAN: Danke.
SALLY: Probiere einmal! Jetzt kann ich den Herd ausschalten.
VOLKAN: Das riecht so schön frisch.
SALLY: Ja, wir wollten einfach wieder etwas Leckeres, Gesundes.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen, wir essen sehr gesund hier,
so mit Sarah und Josh.
Okay, Josh sagt dann immer: „Reicht das für alle?“
VOLKAN: Ich auch.
SALLY: Ja, Volkan auch. Viel Rotkohlsalat, Gemüse, Suppen, Eintöpfe.
Ich glaube, das sind auch die Rezepte, die ihr immer sehen wollt.
VOLKAN: Richtig lecker!
SALLY: Ja?
VOLKAN: Frisch!
SALLY: Ist noch zu hart oder ist gut? Bissfest, gell?
VOLKAN: Nein, das mag ich! Wenn es ein bisschen so ist... viel besser!
SALLY: Ich auch. Schmeckt es gut?
VOLKAN: Schmeckt lecker! Super!
SALLY: Juhuuu! Also, falls ihr das Rezept nachmachen wollt,
dann findet ihr es wie immer in meiner kostenlosen App,
könnt ihr runterladen, das Rezept speichern,
die Einkaufsliste erstellen usw.
Wir setzen uns jetzt hin zum Essen.
Falls ihr noch Rezeptwünsche habt,
schreibt sie auch gern in die Kommentare,
ob ihr eben mehr alltägliche, schnelle Rezepte haben wollt oder
ob es einmal wieder etwas Aufwendiges, Ausführliches sein darf...
Dann schreibt das auch gern.
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
VOLKAN: Ciao!
SALLY: Jetzt mache ich einen Teller für Sarah.
VOLKAN: Schön mit Ingwer. [Sally stimmt zu]. Richtig schön!
SALLY: Ich mag es auch mit Vierlingen, muss ich sagen.
VOLKAN: Wir essen zusammen, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Okay, ich lasse das hier.
SALLY: Ja, wir machen noch ein Foto.
VOLKAN: Richtig lecker!
SALLY: Guck mal, wie lieb! Der Murat hätte es jetzt schon aufgegessen.
Volkan wartet auf uns mit dem Essen.
Murat isst immer alles in 1 Minute.
VOLKAN: Nein, nein, nein!
SALLY: Wir essen gleich zusammen.
VOLKAN: Das war superlecker. Die Zwiebel ist auch so schön frisch.
Das ist ein bisschen wie Vietnamesisch, Thai, ...
SALLY: Ja, stimmt! Ich war zwar noch nie dort,
aber so stelle ich es mir dort vor.
[Musik]